[Music]
audiences were shocked several times
during Avengers endgame but it turns out
the cast may have been even more
gobsmacked when watching the superhero
ensemble it sounds like the actors were
told a blatant lie while shooting one of
the film's most gut-wrenching scenes
warning were officially entering spoiler
country population you chatting with
Jimmy Fallon during his May first
appearance on The Tonight Show Sebastian
Stan the actor who plays Bucky Barnes
spilled a big secret he and his Marvel
co-stars were told they were filming a
wedding scene for Avengers endgame but
it was actually a sequence for the
lakeside funeral of Tony Stark major
bummer the topic came up when Fallon
asked Stan whether he and his cast mates
had any idea what they were filming or
the context of the lines they were
saying we did not for this one we didn't
I mean every everything I I filmed I
found out on the day Stan claims that he
arrived on set one day and noticed that
everyone was dressed to the nines
of course he wondered why no I was told
there was a wedding you know that there
was a wedding that we were filming and I
was like who's getting married of course
Stan now realizes that this was a
complete and utter lie and if you've
seen Avengers endgame you already know
why and then two people weren't there so
that I guess that was the bride in the
groom and perhaps he phrased his comment
this way so that he didn't spoil the
Grimm surprise for The Tonight Show
audience but perhaps he was being
totally serious and actually believed
stark and Scarlett Johansson's Black
Widow were getting married as Marvel
fans now know Black Widow sacrificed
herself in order to save her fellow
Avengers and Tony Stark also passed away
after battling Thanos what Stan didn't
realize is that the scene was actually a
funeral not a wedding of course it would
be unusual for these two characters to
tie the knot an end game especially
since Tony Stark and Gwyneth Paltrow's
Pepper Potts are raising their daughter
Morgan throughout the film
maybe not coincidentally marriage came
up in a separate interview with Bruce
Banner actor Mark Ruffalo during that
conversation confirmed spoilers filler
Ruffalo claimed that Captain America
ties the knot in endgame Alliance
married in this week now we know that
this actually happens in the
after Steve Rogers decides to stay in
the past and marry Peggy Carter could
Ruffalo have been referring to the same
scene that Stan discussed with Fallon on
the other hand Ruffalo admitted that he
received a script for Avengers endgame
that was full of scenes that aren't in
the actual movie I didn't even get a
whole script I don't know why I even got
the script I did get had-had
dummy scenes in it as he says in the
interview he assumed that co-directors
Joe and Anthony Russo included the Fobus
wedding scene in order to throw him off
the scent but Marvel actors are very
familiar with hearing lies and
half-truths during production
spider-man actor Tom Holland once shared
that he had absolutely no idea what
sequences he was shooting for Avengers
infinity war and I was reading what I
thought was a fake script because it was
like spider-man's in space so I didn't
finish it found out it was real Scarlet
Witch actress Elizabeth Olsen
claims that they filmed the
disintegration of even more characters
in infinity war than the ones we see on
screen what's more Ruffalo also revealed
that they had him filmed five very
different endings to the film when the
Russo brothers loosened their grip on
spoilers after it's clear that the
entire universe has finally seen the
film perhaps we'll learn even more
secrets from behind the scenes was Chris
Hemsworth playing fort night between
takes did Chris Evans need to wear butt
pads in order to turn Captain America's
backside into America's on second
thought we'll leave that particular plot
point unspoiled for you check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more lube reveals about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]